[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROHITH RAMKUMAR: So
thank you, everyone,
for doubling down
on your Google Next
'19 experience, showing up on
the very last day for the very
first session.
Considering that somewhat
over-achievement,
we've teed up a session that
both showcases GCP's commitment
to partner-driven innovation,
as well as showcasing
some key solutions
delivered by our data center
and SD-WAN solution partners.
Together we've been
hard at work solving
some of the key challenges
that are only just emerging
with regards to the
Enterprise network.
You've probably noticed that
your network is changing,
at least in four key ways.
An increasingly distributed
hybrid networking set
of assets, as well as a
need to go multi-cloud
for a number of
different reasons.
To build preferred solutions,
picking best of breed services,
to deliver them in
a reliable manner.
And Google promotes this.
We're very open
to that use case,
and we know that it is a use
case that is in proliferation.
All of which needs
to come together
in a highly performant and
reliable manner, with security
being distributed
all across the board.
We have four solutions today
that we'll be showcasing,
starting with Andrew
Leong from Citrix
showcasing their SD-WAN
solution, followed
by Bill Long at Equinix and then
by Matt Simpson at Megaport,
and lastly, Manav Mishra
from Silver Peak Systems,
again with an SD-WAN solution.
So let me transition over.
We will have five minutes at
the end to host a Q&A session,
but without further
ado, let me invite
Andrew to come talk about
the Citrix SD-WAN solution.
ANDREW LEONG: Thank you, Rohith.
Good morning, everyone.
It's a privilege
to be here to share
with you a little
bit about Citrix,
the company, our
SD-WAN solution,
as well as our partnership
with Google, specifically
Google Cloud.
And so I'm Andy Leong.
I run the SD-WAN marketing
program for Citrix.
And while some of you may know
about Citrix as a company,
some of you may not,
and so let me just
start off with a brief intro.
We're a cloud computing company.
We've been around for 30
years, and we're probably
most known for having
created the ICA,
the independent
computing architecture
protocol for virtualization
for desktops, servers,
and applications.
And so we too have been on
this journey towards the cloud,
and along the way we've
actually partnered
with over 400,000 enterprises
across leading industry
verticals, and you can see
some of the samples here.
We have partnerships with large
organizations, institutions
across manufacturing, health
care, retail, financial,
and banking, as well as some
of the top cloud computing
platforms.
And so our portfolio, while
we're known for applications
and what's called the
digital workspace,
we also have a
networking portfolio.
And what is that comprised of?
Well, you've heard,
perhaps over the course
of this past week, what
some of these solutions
and technologies entail.
But effectively, they
traverse the areas of SD-WAN,
security, as well as
application delivery,
or ADC, as some of
you may know that
from a data center perspective.
Now, we also have
analytic solutions,
which also ingest the data
across these applications,
systems, as well as a
network, and actually
contextualizes that so that
IT teams like yourselves
can actually figure out
how to best optimize
your network, your
cloud solutions,
as well as the end
user experience.
Now, some of you may
have heard about SD-WAN,
and as a technology
unto itself, there
are various components,
fundamental components, things
like routing, WAN optimization,
application controls, security,
as well as path
management and control.
Now, we have those
capabilities, and I'm not
going to stand here and
market to this audience here,
but we've decided to actually
take a different approach
to SD-WAN, both in terms of
how we've developed a solution
as well as how we continue
to innovate on it.
And it's really taking the
end user and that experience
into account.
And so we're focused, from
an SD-WAN perspective,
on delivering a superb
exceptional experience
for these applications,
whether they
reside in SaaS environments,
in virtual environments,
or in various IaaS
and PaaS environments.
We obviously need to take
into account security,
and so we make security easy.
So we offer solutions
that actually
protect the assets,
applications, data,
users across network and cloud.
In addition, when it comes
to the journey to cloud,
we make it easier
in that we offer
flexible on-ramps for customers
to extend their enterprise
branches and environments
over to the cloud.
And along with that,
we offer automation
because simplification
without automation?
Well, really, those
are just words.
So how do we deliver
this unique experience?
So what we have that's
built into our solution
is what's called an
application control engine.
And so if you think
about an IT team that
is trying to get
visibility into what's
going across the network, what's
being consumed from the cloud,
they may have visibility
into something like G Suite.
They may have visibility into
applications and protocols.
Well, ultimately, for IT
to really be effective,
they're going to want to
have granular visibility
into is the traffic
real-time in nature?
Is it something via
chat, Google Hangouts?
Is it a chat session?
Is it a voice session?
Is it a Google Drive
sharing session?
And be able to
effectively detect,
automatically classify, and
therefore apply priorities
to those sessions.
And along with that, our
application control engine
has that capability
to detect and optimize
well over 4,500
applications, including many
of the components of G Suite.
And so this, along with our
networking capabilities,
allow our customers
to actually deliver
what we refer to as that always
on, workspace experience.
We also employ capabilities like
deep packet inspection and WAN
optimization to
optimize bandwidth
and the traffic going across
the wide area network.
So this week, we're
pleased to announce
a series of new capabilities
on Google Cloud Platform.
One of them is Citrix
SD-WAN for GCP.
And so this is currently
in field trial.
This will be generally available
in just a few weeks here.
And effectively
what we're doing is
we're making our SD-WAN
appliance, the virtual instance
of it, available on
the GCP marketplace.
And so with this
customers will be
able to effectively download,
check out, if you will,
and then spin up within a VPC,
a Citrix SD-WAN appliance.
And so with that configuration,
branches, data centers,
can be easily connected
to GCP resources
with high availability,
with all the application
performance and quality
that I referenced earlier.
We have capabilities like
dual-ended QoS and last mile
awareness, so that if there are
changing bandwidth conditions,
our network can
adapt to that, again
in the interests of delivering
that better user experience.
And then we've also got
unique capabilities,
like sub-second
failover of links.
And so if customers
in remote locations,
in the case of
retail, they're using
a dedicated internet access
connection via cable or DSL,
they can use 4G LTE as a backup.
And because this failover
occurs in less than seconds,
really, for the
most part, there's
no disruption to
the user experience.
So this is really
just an element
of our broader,
multi-cloud solution where
we give customers optionality.
We effectively give
them choice if they
want to go and connect to GCP.
We recognize that it's a
heterogeneous environment,
so if they want to go to
alternate cloud platforms,
they have that capability.
They can also, when
it comes to SaaS,
we offer capabilities that
utilize a private backbone
to enable the same level of
resiliency in connecting to,
let's say, a workday or a
salesforce.com cloud as well.
And we've also got partnerships
with the likes of Equinix
where, if customers want a
neutral Cloud exchange in order
to multi-cloud into, whether
GCP or any of the other cloud
platforms, they have
that capability as well.
And lastly, with respect
to alternate backbones--
and I recognize this gets
a little bit geeky here--
but as an overlay
to an underlay.
And what does that mean?
Basically, it means an
alternate cloud backbone.
So we have partnerships
with companies
like Teridion in the event
that customers really
want to take it to that
level of sophistication
as far as fine-tuning
their networks.
And so with respect
to security, we
recognize that the attack
vectors are expanding.
And so we have built-in security
controls within our appliances.
We have, essentially, stateful
application firewalls.
We have options via
partnerships to actually bring
on board next
generation firewalls,
as well as, if customers want
to deploy SD-WAN firewall
capabilities within Cloud
environments such as GCP,
they can do that as well.
And then lastly,
because a lot of traffic
is becoming
increasingly consumed
via SaaS and the
public internet,
we have partnerships with the
likes of Zcaler or PaloAlto
and others that actually provide
cloud-based, secure web gateway
capabilities.
And so lastly, with regards
to the simplification
and the automation, we have
a cloud-based management
solution that actually
spins up resources,
not only in branches and
data centers, but also can
connect to cloud solutions,
like some of those we looked at.
We have the ability to
automatically, via a few mouse
clicks, bring up connections
to security solutions,
as well as with
productivity suites.
And so what we're
doing is, over time,
providing more
choice for customers
to actually connect to more
and more productivity suites,
to more cloud solutions.
And so at the end
of the day, it's
about, as customers
go on this journey
to cloud, offering them this
choice, but for the most part,
the application
experience that is
going to keep their
business up and running.
So that's what I have to
share with you this morning.
We've got a booth in
the south hall here.
I believe we are on the
left of the main entrance
and close to the snack bar,
so if anyone has any questions
or wants to get
a little bit more
into detail on our SD-WAN
or networking solutions,
feel free to drop by.
Excuse me.
And also we've got some
revolving theater sessions
as well, and so we
will be covering
SD-WAN as well as other elements
of our networking solution.
And lastly, Rohith and team
have actually put out a blog
this week on Google
Cloud networking,
and so I encourage you
all to check that out.
That's it.
Thank you.
BILL LONG: Good
morning, everybody.
I'm Bill Long with Equinix.
I'm in charge of
the interconnection
products at Equinix.
If I had known this was
the setup I would have
had some Equinix branded
popcorn that you guys could have
or some Junior Mints
you could throw at me
if you didn't like what
I was going to say.
But unfortunately,
I didn't know that.
So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to give--
given where Equinix
sits in the ecosystem,
I'm going to really highlight
what we're seeing in the market
and how people are enabling
cloud connectivity.
So no good presentation these
days starts without a nod
to digital disruption,
and like all cliches,
there's always an
ounce of truth in it.
So we are seeing,
people are really
getting their infrastructure
ready for digital disruption
across all different verticals.
Obviously manufacturing moving
to the industrial internet,
transportation with ride share.
Across the board, it's
happening across all verticals.
And what they're
doing is they're
trying to distribute their
architecture to be ready such
that their
infrastructure is ready
for the digital transformation.
So I mentioned that Equinix sits
in an interesting spot for us
to be able to observe what
enterprises are really doing.
So we have 200 data centers
around the world, 52
different markets,
and the data centers
are a little bit different.
It's not just a big
warehouse full of servers.
Our sweet spot is providing
solutions and ecosystems
where people can actually
connect to each other.
So if you look at the
Cloud Edge nodes that
are deployed globally out
there, about 50% of those
are in Equinix data centers.
So the rest of the industry
splits the other 50%.
So what that gives
us visibility into is
who's connecting to who,
what are they doing with it,
how are they using it, what are
the use cases they're doing?
And so what we've done
is we've analyzed just
over about 800 different
enterprises to look at,
what are the trends that we're
seeing for how people are
transforming their
infrastructure
to be ready for
digital transformation?
And so what we've
noticed is there
are four very distinct steps
that folks are going through.
And typically, they're
in this exact order.
So if you're an
enterprise customer
and you're wondering,
well, how do I
enable this transformation of
making my infrastructure ready
for digital transformation,
this is sort of the roadmap
that we're seeing.
Or if you're a vendor who's
coming up with solutions,
these are the steps
that we're seeing
enterprises take in order to be
ready for that transformation.
So step one is,
typically, they'll
want to optimize their network.
So typically, applications will
be hosted in their basement,
and then all of their users will
be using a wide area network
to get to those applications.
The first step is to distribute
those applications out,
optimize your WAN
is step number one.
So take those applications--
get those applications
closer to the end users
to reduce latency, to
actually drive down costs.
So that's step one.
Typically once enterprises
have optimized their WAN
to distribute out
their applications,
they then use those
nodes to connect out
to enable a multi-hybrid
cloud architecture.
So we'll double click
on that one a little bit
here in a minute.
And then once they have the
distributed architecture
connected out to
the clouds, they
fortify that with a pretty
robust security perimeter.
Once that security
perimeter is there,
we typically see them move
a lot more of their data
closer to those applications.
So that's the rough
progression of what
we see when we look at
these 800 customers of how
they're on this journey.
Double clicking down into
the hybrid multi-cloud, so
what do folks care
about when they're
taking that second step
for hybrid multi-cloud?
Number one, they care
what clouds are available.
So what we see typically
is that, if a customer is
connected to one cloud,
they're most likely
going to connect to at
least two other clouds.
So having that
cloud availability
is absolutely critical.
I mentioned the edge nodes
that Equinix has available.
GCI is available in
Equinix locations
in 22 different metros,
so that's important.
The second big step
is performance.
So you want to make
sure that when you're
deploying your
infrastructure, it's
in a place that's
going to have the best
performance for
connecting into the cloud
that you care about, as well as
provides the option to scale,
both from a performance
standpoint and a cost
standpoint.
So a pattern that we see
from a lot of customers
is they will start
on Cloud Exchange.
So Cloud Exchange is
a platform that you
can set up virtual connections
to multiple clouds.
But once that starts to scale
to 10 gig or multi 10 gig
connections, having the
option to pull that off
to a cross connect is a
really important capability
to have, both for performance as
well as for a cost standpoint.
So pulling that over to
a cross connect and have
that option available is
really important to customers.
And there nine of the 11
regions of the GCI regions
are available in Equinix today.
I think the next
closest competitor
has two locations available.
And then the third
option, of course,
is ease of use and
flexibility, and that
means both technical ease
of use and flexibility,
as well as commercial
flexibility.
So being able to
set up connections.
Obviously when you're
using multi-cloud,
being able to connect
into and out of,
move workloads
around dynamically.
You can set up connections,
tear those connections down
in a very flexible way,
is super important.
So a little bit of a
double click on that.
Through Cloud Exchange, you can
set up connections, tear them
down, to any location
anywhere in the world.
So if you're in Sydney and
you have a workload that
needs to access Google Cloud
in Ashburn or somewhere,
you can use Cloud Exchange to
set that up, or for redundancy.
But again, you can set
that up, tear those down,
in a very flexible architecture.
Two quick use cases
that we're seeing.
The first and probably by
far the predominant use
case that we're
seeing is connecting
on premise or within the
enterprise applications
out to Cloud assets.
So being able to have the
infrastructure that you have
in the cloud appear on
your corporate network
such that you can
have applications
in your own private
enterprise WAN
and be able to access
at those assets
and have them appear on their
same private network, that's
the prime use case number one.
Use case number two is--
we're actually in
limited availability
with this capability now.
We're going to be
rolling it out--
where you can spin up to be able
to do multi-cloud use cases.
So whether you have a data
set that you want to move out
of AWS into GCI, or if
it's an application where
you want to have
compute in one cloud
and you want to have
analytics in another cloud,
being able to set
up a virtual router
and move data into and
out of multiple clouds
is also a second use case.
And you can go to
our booth and we
can show you a demo
of exactly what that's
going to look like as well.
So with that, this
is information
about how to come
and find us, and I'll
be around after the session for
a couple of minutes as well.
Thank you guys.
MATT SIMPSON: OK, good morning.
All right.
I promise it's going to be close
to a blockbuster hit today.
But again, I think
we need the popcorn.
But I'm going to talk a
little bit about Megaport.
Our vision is to
simplify connectivity.
When you're looking at--
I guess Rohith was mentioning
before, multi-cloud,
and also Bill--
it can be very complex.
And I guess our
vision is that we
want to ensure that
you are focused
on getting the best performance
out of your applications.
And so our vision is to simplify
that connectivity and abstract
some of the complexity out of
getting connected to cloud.
But it's not only getting
connected to cloud,
and I think Bill
touched on this as well.
It's a rich, deep
ecosystem out there to get,
of course, full,
end to end solution.
And Megaport, of course,
is about connecting
not only the data centers but
the network providers, managed
service providers, and a
full ecosystem out there.
We have 1350 customers
that connect today
across 425 data centers,
which 82 of those
are unique data
center operators,
so we do have Equinix
and CyrusOne and Cyxtera
and Interxion and Flexential,
and Digital Realty, of course.
So what's unique
about our offering is
that we believe that
it should be fast,
it should be with ease,
and you should have choice,
because at the end
of the day, you
need to be focused on
those applications.
So we touched on over
the last five years,
Megaport has been
building out layer
two, a software-defined
network, an open and neutral
interconnection platform.
And over the last
five years we've
been building out to those data
centers a redundant network
across all of those
facilities, and generally
that's where those
service providers live,
all those
interconnection points.
And so over the past
five years, our customers
have been connecting
at layer two.
But what we have been
seeing is customers
are wanting that cloud
to cloud connectivity,
and whilst they might
have infrastructure,
that hybrid scenario
with layer two,
they're also looking
at connecting cloud
to cloud without going
and procuring network
hardware and space and power.
So across the 425, you can
establish a service or a port
with our particular service
anywhere across the globe.
It takes a couple of
minutes to provision.
And you can also scale that
bandwidth in real time.
So I'm going to touch a little
bit about Megaport Cloud
Router.
It's a solution
that our customers
were coming to us about,
and it was, I have my data.
I've got my on-prem and
I'm connecting to cloud.
But now I want to look at
connecting the two cloud
endpoints.
So in this scenario, it's a
private, layer three service,
and you can establish this at
a one gig, two and 1/2 gig,
or even 10 gig if you like.
And this is a managed layer
three connectivity service.
So what we have done
with this virtual router
is abstracted some of
that configuration,
and it also allows you to,
if you don't have your own AS
or your own IP, then
this device will actually
manage that for you and
automatically assign.
So in a typical scenario
a customer may come to us
and say, OK, I want to have
a little bit of mixture
of on-prem and then a cloud,
with a hybrid scenario,
and then they'll also
look at cloud to cloud.
So I'm using this diagram
as a bit of an overview
of a virtual router.
I've stood it up in
a particular zone,
and then I've got that variety
of multiple cloud services
there.
So in this case, we do provide
the service across both GCP,
across 23 of the interconnect
points across the globe,
and we also provide
direct peering,
which is the layer
three service, which
gives you access to Google's
public resources as well.
And so I wanted to
share with you--
it's not working that well
on this particular screen.
But a typical customer
scenario might have--
media and entertainment
is a great one.
For animation and
rendering, they're
looking for burstable traffic.
It's seasonal, and they may
have their infrastructure in LA.
And they'll establish a
layer two port with us,
and they'll connect to
multiple different services
within the West Coast of the US.
But what if they had their
application in the east coast
and they wanted to stand that
up pretty quickly and storage
and compute might be
an AWS, but they're
looking to get access to
some of the analytics on GCP.
With this Megaport
cloud router, you
can spin up the virtual device
within a couple of minutes
and have virtual
cross connections
between GCP and AWS.
So, a private, layer
three connection.
It doesn't touch
the public internet.
And then if you want
to, you can actually
connect those to our
services back to West Coast
if you want to for
a one-off migration.
In that particular
scenario, then you
can turn that device off
after you've used it,
whether it be a month, a day,
or a year, or even an hour.
The choice is yours.
We talked a little bit about
the application and seasonal
and bursting of traffic, and
what we've done with Megaport
is we've aligned our business
model similar to cloud.
So you can actually spin
up your private connection
from one megabit right
up to 100 gigabits
if you like, and you can
actually do that on demand.
And in this scenario, with our
particularly seasonal traffic,
you can manipulate those
speeds whenever you need to,
whether it be on a weekend,
whether it be on an evening,
and we'll only bill you for
what you actually consume.
We've got a couple of
customers, particularly media
and entertainment,
that are actually
chasing some of
that cheap storage
and compute, particularly
whatever provider
that might be.
We've had scenarios where a
customer might go from Toronto
right down to Ashburn, and with
a virtual cross connection,
they could do that for a month.
And what's really important is--
Thomas talked about an
open ecosystem this week,
and with Megaport, we've
got that neutral platform
that you can connect
to multiple services
across 425 data centers,
across 120 cloud on-ramps,
across multiple cloud providers.
And it's really important
that, with Google, there's
58 points of presence.
They've got one of
the largest networks.
But with Megaport,
you're actually
connecting from 425
points of those locations.
So we're extending
the reach of GCP
and bringing it to the doorstep
to you as the enterprise user.
And that's really important
from a performance
and getting the best of
out of your application.
I think that's pretty much it.
So of course, like everyone
here, we've got a booth.
I'll be here for the
rest of the morning,
and I look forward to
discussing it with you.
Thanks very much.
MANAV MISHRA: Let me
get this thing straight.
Hi.
This is Manav.
I work for Silver Peak.
I run Product Management
for Silver Peak.
For those of you who
don't know Silver Peak,
Silver Peak is a company
that has been around
for about a decade or so.
We focused earlier on
on run optimization,
and a few years ago, we were
one of the early vendors,
early products in
the space that's
now known as software-defined
wide area networks.
So why are we different from
other products and services
in the space?
Part of the reason
is we have always
taken a business intent driven
and apps driven approach
to networking.
So essentially what
we realized was
enterprises, small
businesses, medium businesses,
customers, cared more about
taking their business intent
and business policies
and transforming them
into network configurations,
network policies, firewall
rules, routing
policies, and whatnot.
And what we provide is
an abstraction to all
of that, a simple abstraction
that can take a human readable,
a human prescribable policy
for the treatment an enterprise
admin wants the
application or the service
to have, and get that translated
all the way down to the router,
to the data plane, in terms
of actionable policies.
What we achieve by doing that
is the quality of experience.
So as we know, as the
world is progressively
moving towards SaaS
and SaaS applications,
the quality of performance
of those applications
is largely dictated by the
ability of the networking
infrastructure to know when
to intelligently break out
the traffic, which public
cloud presence to send
the traffic to, and to afford
the right performance for audio
and video over internet.
Our solution is also
built on the notion
of continuous adaptation, and
what I mean by that is it's
a self-learning and a
self-driving network.
So looking at the data that
flows into the customer's
network, we automate a
bunch of different things
on behalf of the customer.
We develop the learning
of packet identification,
application identification,
and we have this technology
called First Packet IQ
Technology, which can,
looking at the very first packet
over a new application type,
it can detect what the
application is, and then
decide, based on the
identification, what
corresponding policy
to apply to it,
whether that application
or that packet
needs to be back-hauled all the
way back to HQ or to the data
center, or it needs
to break out locally.
And we are continuously
learning it at every node,
at every router in
the network, and we
use that to make the network
more intelligent and more
adaptive.
Finally, what we also realized
working with our customers,
is that no two
customers are alike.
There are some
customers who want
to overhaul their entire
existing infrastructure.
They want to take what they have
put in place over the last 10
years and move to this new world
of software-defined wide area
networks.
And then there are
customers who actually
want an SD-WAN solution
that will play nicely,
that will fit in with
the existing network,
so we call it Greenfield
or Brownfield deployments.
And for Brownfield
deployments, we
need to have a solution that
supports a lot of the existing
protocol infrastructure
that customers
have in place, so
things like BGP, OSPF,
things like multicast virtual
routing and forwarding
capabilities.
So we have a unified
solution that
brings in the best of
software-defined wide area
networks and mixes it with
existing infrastructure
so that any type of
customer can use our product
and be successful.
Our success has been
recognized by Gartner,
so Gartner has
started publishing
what they call the Magic
Quadrant for the WAN Edge.
Every technology that we call
by a particular name, Gartner
has its own name for it.
So software-defined
wide area networks
is called WAN Edge by Gartner.
We are one of the three
leaders in the Magic Quadrant.
I want to talk a little
bit about our platform,
and then talk about how we
enable successful Google Cloud
customers.
Our platform, essentially, is an
all unified, Cloud-first stack
which has application
visibility and control.
This is the packet
detection, identification,
intelligent breakout
that I talked about.
It has routing capabilities, so
essentially interplaying nicely
with OSPF, BGP,
Multicast, VRF, name it.
It has WAN optimization,
so our company's roots
were in WAN optimization,
so WAN optimization
is a built-in,
integrated feature.
So for customers who want
WAN op, and there are still
a lot of customers who have
their own private cloud
offerings who need
WAN optimization,
it's easy to enable
using our product.
And network security.
So we have built-in firewalls
and built-in segmentation
that customers can
use so that they
don't need to have
yet another appliance
to afford these capabilities
for their network.
And all of these
are built into what
we call the EdgeConnect
Appliance, the Unity
EdgeConnect Appliance.
Now, the software is available
in a virtualized form,
so if you want to run it
on-prem or on a hypervisor,
you could do so.
It's available in the cloud.
We are the only
product out there
which is available on
all major public clouds.
So you can actually go
to Google Marketplace
as your marketplace,
AWS marketplace, Oracle
marketplace, and you can
easily get it and deploy it
in a VPC of your choice.
And it also comes with
Silver Peak hardware.
So for your branch
offices where you
want a local point of presence
for the software in a branch
office, you can actually get
a hardware and software combo
from Silver Peak.
So this is essentially
our data plane.
This is where the
magic actually happens.
But how does the data
plane know what to do,
and how does the data plane
know what policies are
being configured by the user?
And that happens through what
we call the orchestration plane.
So we have a centralized,
business-driven orchestration
solution.
I think it's available
in three different forms.
It's available in a SaaS form.
We call it Orchestrator
as a service,
so we run it in our
public cloud presence.
And as a customer, think of
it just like a SaaS product.
You can log into the
portal, you get access
to your orchestration
for your network,
and you can manage and configure
your network from there.
It's also available
on-prem, so you
can actually, if you have your
own on-prem infrastructure,
all you need to do is
have a hypervisor layer
and deploy this OVA,
or the hypervisor
format of your choice, onto
your existing infrastructure.
Or just like with the
virtual appliance,
you can run it in a VPC in any
of the major public clouds.
So you can run it on Google,
Amazon, Microsoft, Oracle.
So this is sort of
the net net of what
our overall product looks like.
We also have an integrated
service training platform
built into the product
by which, if you
want to intelligently break out
traffic to a security service
provider, like Zscaler or a
PaloAlto or a Checkpoint--
I'm going to cover
in a subsequent slide
a list of our partners--
you could do so.
And the orchestration
to Zscaler is automated.
So essentially all you
need to do is, in the UI,
you just need to
define the policy.
For traffic you could
say, hey, all the traffic
that's going to my
corporate websites,
send it back to the data
center, and anything
that's going out to the
internet, send it to Zscaler.
And then behind the scenes,
we work with Zscaler,
we find out the local points
of presence for Zscaler
that are closer to
that branch office,
and we automate the tunnel
creation between all sites
and the corresponding
Zscaler points of presence
worldwide for the customer
with just one click.
We also have flow
through operations,
so essentially everything
that we do in the product
is available by a Rest APIs.
So it's a cloud-first approach
to building the product.
So if you want to have access
to the detailed statistics
and analytics and
logs that we have,
we make it available
to our customers.
And we have customers
using that and syncing it
into their own data analytics
systems and data warehousing
systems.
We have a Splunk connector
for a bunch of our enterprise
customers who use it.
They import the data from
our systems into Splunk
and then they do their own
detailed analysis and insight
gathering from that.
The Unity EdgeConnect
Appliance--
I'm just going to
quickly cover this.
As I said, it's available
in a physical, virtual, and
cloud-based form.
It runs Unity Boost, which is
our WAN optimization feature.
It has fast packet detection.
The one thing I wanted
to touch over here
is we have zero touch
branch deployments,
so we have zero touch
provisioning and zero touch
configuration.
So essentially, if
you're an IT admin
and you want to send a
replacement box into a branch
office in your
organization but you
want to preconfigure
all the policies for it,
you could actually just use
our scripts, use our Rest APIs.
We configure the box, and when
the branch office gets the box,
all they have to do is open
it up and plug in the cables
and it's good to go.
Or you can use zero
touch provisioning,
which is where we ship a new
box to the branch office,
the branch office connects
the box to cables,
goes into the Orchestrator,
Orchestrator shows
that a new device or a new
appliance has been detected,
and then you let the
orchestrator orchestrate it
on your behalf.
So essentially think of it
as the modern Pixel or iPhone
experience where
you just have to log
in with your username and
ID, and the policies and data
that you have for that
particular device automatically
are provisioned
through the cloud.
So this is a list
of our partners.
As I said, we work
with a variety of them.
PaloAlto, Zscaler, CheckPoint,
Forcepoint, Symantec.
The list is endless.
Coming on to how we enable
success for Google and Google
Cloud customers.
As I mentioned, our
virtual appliance
is available on
Google Cloud today.
You could give it a try.
We have quite a few
customers who have deployed
and are using Silver Peak
on Google Cloud today,
and they are using Silver
Peak on Google Cloud in two
different deployment models.
So we have customers who
are new in their journey
to Google Cloud,
or who basically
want to enable a cloud on-ramp
for a particular organization
within their enterprise.
So they basically create a
single VPC on Google Cloud
and then deploy our EdgeConnect
appliance onto that.
And then we also have more
complicated and complex
deployments where customers
have a large presence on Google
Cloud and they have a bunch
of different apps, services,
data sets residing
on Google Cloud
and they want access
to all of these
to the rest of the enterprise.
And what they do is they deploy
Silver Peak on Google Cloud,
use a load balancer,
and use that to serve
all the different VPCs that
they have in the infrastructure.
So the two use cases that
we're seeing a lot of traction
on in the market today.
The first one is essentially
the cloud on-ramp,
which is customers who want
to extend their enterprise
into the cloud, and they
essentially want a protected--
I call it the protected
first-mile, or last-mile,
depending on how
you look at it--
connectivity from the
branch into the cloud.
And then the second trend
that we have started seeing,
and we actually are working
very closely with at least three
or four customers right now
on, is the multi-cloud journey
where they have different
points of presence
on different clouds,
and these clouds could
be public or private.
So we have one customer
who has data on AWS
and they run the
service on Google Cloud,
and they want a high-speed,
multi-cloud connection
fabric between these two
clouds, and essentially all they
do is they extend the enterprise
infrastructure into Amazon
by deploying an ECV there.
They extend the
infrastructure into Google
by deploying an ECV there.
And then Silver
Peak SD-WAN fabric
thinks of these as new
branches in the cloud
and does the needful to
make sure that connectivity
is guaranteed.
[MUSIC PLAYING]